moose how are you this morning I'm good
dad how are you doing great your
favorite piece of sports memorabilia you
have oh wow I got a 500 home run bat
Mickey Mantle had donated an auction
item to us prior to him getting cancer
and then he was not going to be able to
make the event as he went through
treatment so he gave us his own 500
autographs home run back at the time and
it SAT there at the auction so I bought
it myself any any cowboy memorabilia
that you kept while playing oh yeah I've
got I've got a really nice picture of
Troy and Emmett 9 in the backfield on a
play that they've signed and it gave me
a fantastic painting by Vernon Wells for
Christmas one year that sits in my
office so but other than that you know
we we've got some of the Super Bowl
pictures what I haven't got him signed
but there's there's a lot of stuff
that's the mean stuff personal to me but
if you were to if summer was to look at
it you know there's not the signatures
on it to bring it value but for me it
means a lot how surprised were you that
that giant saints game ended up being
low scoring well I knew it was going to
match the 52-49 that we had the year
before we actually did that game so I
knew it wasn't going to be that the
Giants defense was with so much improved
from last year I was concerned about the
secondary of the Saints I didn't expect
a close game I thought it was going to
be a 10 or 14 point giant victory so the
way the game came out at the end at just
16 13 to me not only the low scoring but
as close as it was I thought New Orleans
defense did a very nice job yesterday
against uh what I consider is probably
going to be one of the better offenses
in the league as we get in the november
and december for the Giants did you
watch the Rams yesterday I don't you get
a chance to watch anything you know I
didn't dan I didn't get to see that game
at all it's amazing that Seattle with
Russell Wilson and their defense and
there they are trying to beat the rams
at home and they score three points I
know we nor
we overreact with the NFL but after two
when can you overreact when can you just
react in the NFL and say okay now we got
an issue here this is two weeks is that
enough I think I interesting stuff this
week the biggest improvement or when you
start to define yourself is week two
because it's such an unknown coming into
the opener because nobody really shows
anything in preseason you don't really
know who everybody is yet but but week
to you kind of have a better idea of the
week one performance and you start to
gameplan towards that so I think you can
start to formulate your opinion in week
two and then I think if you continue to
play that way if it's if it does become
consistent in your performance that as
we get to the latter part of that first
quarter you may have some issues with
that franchise and I think what's
interesting in Seattle is is we see a
lot of teams around the NFL kind of
following the model that Dallas went
heavy on draft picks and their offensive
line over the last five six years
they've really concentrated on upgrading
the offensive line and we've seen other
teams do that now you know even talking
to ben mcadoo you know who I would
consider you know an offensive-minded
head coach quarterback coach working
with Mike McCarthy but but his
background is in to the offense of the
defensive line for some reason Seattle
uses that is kind of their flex piece
under their salary cap they've got their
key guys that they want to have Russell
Wilson Bobby Wagner Earl Thomas kam
chancellor you know they've got those
guys you know that they consider to be
the core of that group of Richard
Sherman and then they're adding pieces
around but when you do that you know
they don't have they don't have that
left tackle anymore they let Russell
Okung go in three agencies so their
offensive line becomes that bargaining
chip and I think it's coming back the
vitamins you can only ask Tom Cable to
do so much year after year trying to
convert a defensive tackle to a guard or
trying to make a guard a tackle or a
tackle of guards so we're gonna have to
wait and see how this experiment works
this year but I had some concerns about
Seattle because of the change in their
offensive line this year from one that
was suspect last year I think they're
relying on Russell Wilson too much to
avoid the pressure he's Darryl moose
Johnston the NFL on Fox joining a Stan
Patrick show Jimmy Groppo we're not sure
if he's going to miss one to two or
maybe more after injuring his shoulder
and now you bring in a kid that was
drafted ahead of dak Prescott you know
they they drafted him in the third round
but is this more about just Belichick is
going to insulate the court whoever the
quarterback is it doesn't matter with
that offense that he has I think it's
amazing what Bill Belichick and his
staff are able to do you know one of the
reasons I think that that Tom Brady has
to be considered the best quarterback to
play in the NFL is he's never had that
that group of guys around him for a
consistent period of time you know you
can when you go and look at what New
England has done through the years and
the success that they've had you know
they've done it with a strong running
game playing defense they've done it
with two tight ends they've done it with
Edelman in the slot and moss on the
outside the one fixture has always been
tom so I've always been impressed with
that so this is just another this is
just another example of or a challenge
for Bill Belichick and his staff but I
think they've been so good at what
they've done in the past it this will be
challenging for them but if anybody's
going to be able to navigate this over
the next two weeks it's going to be
Bella check and his staff you need a
backup quarterback I mentioned Tim Tebow
who knows the system he's in great shape
and maybe you could get him in there for
one or two weeks is that too much too
much Tim Tebow to bring in to the
Patriots of all the organizations you
can bring him in and it doesn't become
Tebow time like it would anyplace else
well he'd be he'd be a stopgap and that
would be something you know right along
the lines that the developed and his
staff would would probably consider and
be able to make workable it's funny in
our game as we SAT with Sean Payton on
Saturday and we were kind of talking
about different things and we got into
Tommy Lee Lewis and you know how you
know Sean will still call Bill Parcells
and bill will call Shawn and you know
Bill had worked with Tommy Lee down in
Florida getting him ready for the draft
but the name that came up was the
quarterback in New England right now and
you know bill also said he got to take a
look at the kid at NC State you know
he's he's going to be a legitimate
prospect next year in the draft and Sean
looked at him and he was very interested
with him and then he went to the
Patriots so it was it was really strange
yesterday that we heard this whole
conversation about a guy who I was not
really from
earlier with and then later that
afternoon course of the game he's thrust
into the spotlight and we've already got
inside information on him from Sean
Payton from Bill Parcells and then
obviously you know Bill Belichick and
his group up there getting ready for the
draft saw the same thing that these two
had talked about that he has the
legitimate skills to be a prospect in
the NFL and I thought % look good when
he came in there and I don't know if
it's the system we get caught up in that
that it's Bella check system plugs
somebody in there Garoppolo look very
good now we're going to find out when
you when you put this kid in there to
start against JJ Watt in company is it
the system or we're gonna learn a lot
more we learn a lot more now Jimmy
Garoppolo played against he played well
against Arizona which is a good defense
yeah you know Miami Miami has has the
potential to be but I still think
they're in transition right now we're
going to learn a lot more about exactly
about that system and how that
quarterback functions that system
against Houston that's a that's a pretty
good front that he's going to see this
weekend but have you seen enough of a
sample size with Garoppolo where you
know he's got what after 2017 then he's
done you know would somebody jump in on
unwrapped low or do we overeat because
he's with the Patriots no no I think he
becomes a very very sought-after
commodity remember we're really
struggling to skoo got 32 teams in the
NFL you know there's there's definitely
people that are concerned about the
ability to get that quality back up
behind your starter and in this Jimmy
Garoppolo now the two teams look at him
as a legitimate starter after his
performance in week 1 and before he got
hurt against Miami I think that he's
always known all along with Tom Brady
continuing talking about how long he
wants to play out into the future that
this is as much an audition for him for
his next stop as it is to solidify his
spot as the successor to Tom Brady when
his career comes to an end so I think
it's going to be very interesting to see
how New England navigates this whole
thing because I think that Jimmy
Garoppolo will be sought after when his
contract expires and he's open to the
free market there was a lot of talk
about him coming out in the draft he has
had the opportunity to learn the system
for
the best quarterback to play the game in
many people's opinion you saw how well
he played on the big stage at Arizona
that night so I think he definitely has
put himself in a position for teams to
make a run at him when his when his
contract ends up and it's going to be
interesting to see what the response of
the New England Patriots is good stuff
moves thanks for joining us safe travels
you got it down always a pleasure
talking with you the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience